supongamos que eres un filósofo de la
antigüedad que está construyendo las
bases de las matemáticas ya tienes una
comprensión razonable lo que un número
negativo representa o debería
representar ya sabes cómo sumar o restar
números negativos pero ahora te
encuentras con un dilema qué pasa cuando
multiplicas los números negativos ya sea
que multiplique su número negativo por
un número positivo o que multiplique
estos números negativos así que tú no
estás seguro de lo que pasa si
multiplicas un número positivo y un
número negativo y voy a tomar dos
números cualesquiera qué pasa si
multiplicas 5 por menos 3 no estás
seguro de lo que pasa tampoco está
seguro de lo que pasa si multiplicas los
números negativos por ejemplo si
multiplicas menos 2
-6 tienes duda de qué es lo que pasa lo
que si sabes como matemático es que no
importa como tú de finas estas
operaciones deben de ser consistentes
con las propiedades desarrolladas
previamente en particular con las
propiedades de multiplicación
específicamente las propiedades de la
multiplicación esto te va a dar
confianza de porque esto funciona
posteriormente encontraremos maneras de
desarrollar la intuición de porque esto
funciona y porque hace sentido así que
para hacer esto consistente con el resto
de las matemáticas que conoces haces un
pequeño experimento te preguntas cuánto
resulta de multiplicar 5 por 3 más menos
3 ya cuentas con la filosofía de lo que
sucede al sumar números positivos o
números negativos sabes que menos 3 es
opuesto a 3 y al sumar 3 con menos 3
obtienes 0 así que esto de aquí va a ser
igual esto va a ser igual a 5 x
pero basado en que sumar un negativo y
un positivo se cancelan entonces esto va
a ser igual y cualquier número x 0 es
igual a cero así que esta expresión de
aquí debe ser igual a 0 por otro lado te
planteas que quieres que la
multiplicación de números positivos o
negativos sea consistente con la
propiedad distributiva así que voy a
distribuir este 5 voy a distribuir este
5 y para que las matemáticas sean
consistentes pues deben de ser
consistentes debo de obtener exactamente
el mismo resultado así que voy a
destruir el 5 entonces 5 por 3 5 por 3
lo voy a desarrollar aquí abajo 5 por 3
déjame usar en vez del punto mejor la
cruz para indicar el x 5 x 3
estoy distribuyendo esto más
5 x menos 3 dejan usar el amarillo 5 x
menos 35 x menos 3 y todo esto ya vimos
que es igual a cero
esto es igual a 0 y aquí que tenemos 5 x
estos números positivos ya sabemos que
eso es igual a 15
más más lo que sea que resulte de 5 x
menos 3 lo que sea que resulte de 5 x
menos 3 y esto tiene que ser igual a 0
para que sea consistente con las
matemáticas que sabemos y entonces que
sumado a 15 va a ser igual a cero esto
tiene que ser lo opuesto a 15 así que
para que esto sea consistente con todas
las matemáticas que sabemos esto tiene
que ser igual a menos 15 entonces
establece es que esto de aquí para que
sea consistente con todas las
matemáticas que conoces tiene que ser
igual a menos 15 y esto también es
consistente con la intención de sumar
repetidamente 5 veces menos 3 ahora es
un poco más difícil de concebir la
multiplicación entre dos números
negativos pero podemos concebir un
experimento mental similar al que
acabamos de hacer queremos cualquiera
que sea la respuesta de esto que sea
consistente con las matemáticas que
sabemos así que hacemos el mismo
experimento mental cuanto resulta de
multiplicar menos 2
6 + menos 666 es igual a cero menos 2 x
0 de hecho cualquier cosa multiplicada
por 0 es igual a 0 de nueva cuenta
podemos distribuir el menos 2 - 2 por 6
menos 2 por 6
más
más menos 2 x menos 6 más menos 2 x
menos 6 y de nueva cuenta todo esto
tiene que ser igual a 0 ahora basados en
el experimento mental que acabamos de
hacer esto tiene que ser igual a menos
12 o también podríamos pensar que si nos
movemos 6 unidades a la izquierda del 0
2 veces obtenemos menos 12 o también
podemos conseguirlo como si sumamos
repetidamente menos 26 veces
obtendríamos menos 12 y eso también lo
vimos aquí que si multiplicamos un
número positivo por un número negativo
obtenemos un número negativo así es que
esto va a ser igual al menos 2 por 6 va
a ser igual a menos 12 así tenemos menos
12 más lo que sea que resulte de esto
menos 2 x menos 6 lo que sea que resulte
de esto y esto tiene que ser igual a 0
para que sea consistente con todas las
matemáticas que sabemos entonces que
sumado con menos 12 va a ser igual a 0
bueno 12 positivo más 12 negativo tiene
que ser igual a 0 así es que esto va a
ser igual a 12
para ser consistente con todas las
matemáticas que sabemos de ahí obtenemos
el resultado de que esto va a ser igual
a 12 positivo 12 positivo vamos a
dejarlo aquí y voy a realizar otros
vídeos donde puedas ver conceptualmente
por qué esto es verdadero